good afternoon everyone my name is dr.
Miller and the SCP were going to be
looking at today is SCP 29
[Music]
Keter special containment procedures SCP
29 66 is to be contained at outpost 117
and at no time shall any other SCP
objects be contained with it a liquid
fluoride thorium reactor is to be
powered at all times with the heat
exchange directly in thermodynamic
contact with SCP 29 6 T 6 is housing
before usage of SCP 29 6 T 6
monitors will ensure that there are at
least two point o four times 10 to the
power of 17 joules of heat energy
available to thermodynamically transfer
into a CP 29 66 is housing during use
this heat energy transfer will be
carefully monitored to match the rate of
matter removal a skeleton crew shall
occupy outpost 117 to minimize the risk
of casualties this crew shall consist of
three persons trained in the maintenance
and upkeep of a liquid fluoride thorium
reactor for research personnel to
monitor both SCP 29 6 T six estate and
the state of the reactor to form an
squads of security personnel to patrol a
25-kilometer perimeter around outpost
117 s location and deter civilian
entrance and one d-class personnel to
use as CP 29 66 AD class shell use s CP
29 6 T 6 three times per day at 8 hour
intervals o 800 1620 400 where use is
defined as the removal of at least ten
sheets from SCP 29 6 t 6 use is to be
heavily monitored and contact shall be
kept with the d-class subject at all
times during said use in order to
modulate the speed with which SCP 29
a regulator placed on the reactor shell
accordingly adjust energy output to
match inevitable changes in the rate at
which SCP 29 6 T 6 is used a scale
attached to SCP 29 6 T 6 s housing shall
determine its mass at all times and
relay set information to monitoring
staff construction of an airstrip for
jet aircraft is currently undergoing
evaluation as a possible means of escape
should SCP 29 6 T 6
reached the critical stage as well as a
means for connection to larger adjacent
foundation sites description SCP 29 6 t
6 is an anomalous role of bran toilet
paper the role currently averages a mass
of around kilograms though attempting to
reduce this mass is discouraged as a
result of incident 20 966 35 a toilet
paper sheets removed from a CP 20 966
are beyond being incredibly effective at
removing stray fecal matter
non-anomalous and energetically stable
the roll section of SCP 29
to a wall mounting which has no means
for accessing the roll for replacement
or removal non-invasive testing of the
housing has not yet yielded a clear
picture of what is inside the housing
and invasive testing is discouraged due
to SCP 29 6 T 6 is volatile nature in
addition the housing serves as the main
heat sink for the thermal transfer
between SCP 29 6 T 6 and the
reactor damaging the thermodynamic
connection may result in SCP 29 29 66 is
anomalous in that it is effectively an
infinite roll of toilet paper
since containment started in
approximately kilometers of toilet paper
has been removed from a CP 20 966 no
means of inputting mass or more toilet
paper have been observed and testing has
revealed no temporal retrieval of
additional paper from a different
location or dimension the mechanism by
which SCP 29 6 t 6 accomplishes this is
entirely unknown though its effects are
well understood as CP 29 66 obeys the
laws of mass energy conservation and
through unknown means absorbs energy
from its surroundings in order to create
the matter that makes up the toilet
paper one sheet of SCP 29
which means that approximately 2.0 4
times 10 to the power of 16 joules of
energy or roughly 65 tons of TNT is
needed for one sheet of SCP 29 6 T 6 to
be produced it is estimated that there
are sheets formed within the role of SCP
29 66 or a yield of the megatons of TNT
if more than 10 sheets are removed at
one time from a CP 29 66 it will absorb
the energy around it at roughly the rate
at which sheets are removed the form of
energy absorbed is most often heat
energy though a CP 29 66 does not appear
to have a preference testing has shown
that ambient sound energy has also been
decreased during use without an external
source of energy to provide power to SCP
29th of energy needed to form one sheet
to 0.04 times 10 to the power of 16
joules is absorbed from the ambient heat
of the surroundings quickly bringing the
temperature of all matter within a
radius of meters to near absolute zero
this has happened twice during power
failures both times on-site staff have
sacrificed themselves to remove ten
sheets
killing themselves through hypothermia
instantly while not a sustainable
containment solution such a sacrifice
has prevented SCP 29 6 T 6 from going
critical
if SCP 29 6 T 6 is not used it will
begin to lose the matter it is gained
turned into energy once more at a rate
given as e n joules per second where n
is the number of minutes since last use
this energy is radiated away in the form
of heat and occasionally alpha particles
the optimum balance between usage and
radiation has been determined to be
slightly more than eight hours reflected
in the special containment procedures as
this rate increases exponentially as CP
29 66 will reach a critical stage
approximately hours after last use in
which the rate of energy radiation will
rapidly approach infinity effectively
this results in SCP 29 6 T 6
converting its remaining mass entirely
to energy in an instant this is
estimated to produce roughly 1 times 10
to the power joules of energy or an
explosion with a yield of megatons
despite outpost 117 remote location a
fully critical SCP 29 6 T 6 situation is
estimated to produce casualties in
excess of what the foundation is
equipped to handle during usage of SCP
29 6 T 6
d-class subjects have reported an
occasional decrease in room temperature
d-class have also reported that the
paper removed from a CP 20 966 is
exceptionally comfortable effective and
strong requests for sheets removed from
a CP 29 66 to be rear old and used that
Foundation facilities have been denied
twenty-nine sixty-six recovery long SCP
29 6 T six was discovered after
foundation agents noticed an anomalous
temperature drop in CA from data
recorded by the National Weather Service
in a subsequent investigation by a
mobile task force theta 19 rocketeers
revealed that one pine Ranger research
had been frozen over in an area of about
one kilometer square despite it being a
warm summer day data returned by MTF
theta 19 indicates that the temperature
of the area had been approximately minus
108 degrees Celsius far lower than any
temperature naturally recorded on earth
as to why the area was not absolute zero
research has suggested that the usage of
SCP 29 6 T 6 and occurred several hours
earlier in which the Sun had time to
warm the area
MTF theta 19 breached the building and
found that all present in the building
had been killed as a result of the
temperature drop a researcher later
identified as dr. was discovered after
apparently giving a demonstration to
several others holding a C P 29 66 the
effects of SCP $29 on excite corrupted
the snow data can be obtained as to how
a CP 20 966 was created
however MTF se 219 did discover a
handwritten journal belonging to dr. in
his office and while the pages were
covered in frost parts of the journal
were recovered and able to be read C
document 29 6600 one several locals had
noticed the rapid temperature drop a
cover story of a ruptured liquid
nitrogen tank was disseminated and Class
A amnestics administered a C P 29 66 was
studied in situ in the following hours
after a secure perimeter had been
established its properties determined
and successfully contained
document 2960 601 today we have achieved
a breakthrough in toilet paper
technology not a single man will need to
feel the burning pain of an uncleaned
another region ever again
moreover this will likely make me
exceedingly rich once we figure out how
to make other paper products like
tissues and maybe even plates a minor
setback has occurred with the Infinity P
project we can't produce cellulose
fibres fast enough to make a truly
infinite row a possible solution is the
liberal application of haft hafnium
otherwise known as quaternion
while exceedingly rare and expensive
sacrifices must be made in the pursuit
of science while the others call me a
fool I think that in this day and age
anyone with a doctorate should be able
to understand others work even if it's
in a different branch that's just good
science if you can write well enough for
the layman to understand who cares if
I'm a botanist I should be able to
decipher dr. paper on quarterly 'm note
no such element known as quaternion
exists
the housing is complete we've added the
initial paper and soon the quarter
Nemeth alloy will be complete or
insertion into the hyperbaric
containment field of course the other
arrays have proven themselves to be an
issue but they shouldn't terribly hamper
the production of the Fermi impairs no
the rest of the entry is illegible it
appears that the threshold energy for
the Fermi impaired production is
slightly higher than my calculations
suggest no matter I'll just rework the
calculations with Fermi estimation and
that should put us in a good place to
test tomorrow
soon the world will never need toilet
paper again note after this entry are
several partially legible equations
solved by hand thorough hand
calculations were done by foundation
physicists with the same constants which
revealed the doctor apparently misplaced
the square an e equals mc-squared
early in his work this led to
substantially lower energies than in
reality
possibly reinforcing dr. the idea that
he could create matter from energy
safely incident 2960 635 a test 2960 635
a was conducted an attempt to see if a
reduction in mass could be achieved by
rapid removal of SCP 29 6 T 6 sheets
while supplying an excess of energy this
resulted in SCP 29 66 immediately going
critical
the subsequent energy released times 10
to the power joules destroyed outpost
117 and resulted casualties due to
outpost 117 s remote location no
non-foundation casualties were reported
as CP 29 66 was recovered unharmed and
weight grams less our post 117 has since
been rebuilt and containment
re-established
indestructible lizards living masks
skinny dudes who don't like their faces
looked at the weirdest [ __ ] you could
possibly imagine and I'm doing a lecture
on its affinity toilet paper I love my
job sometimes anyway I think that about
does it for today thank you all for
listening if indeed you still are and
you are all dismissed goodbye
[Music]
I would like to give a special thank you
to the reclusive extrovert GM's Sabah
Chris all Pablo ice 917 Caleb
Chaffins Kareem el ash Mui Justin de
Brocker Imam Thomas Morin Curie kuma
white crew and jayvo jack crystal spice
my archive curator Nick King modding and
the wanderer thank you all so much for
your support
it's greatly appreciated if you would
like a special thank you at the end of
each of my videos on some other cool
stuff as well visit patreon.com forward
slash the volga thank you
you